[Musik]
hier ist das Einkaufszentrum Gagarin für
Informationen drücken Sie die 1 um mit
der Geschäftsleitung zu sprechen
[Musik]
guten Morgen Ich habe einige Dokumente
für alle Jura auf und sie haben mir
diese Adresse gegeben
[Musik]
die ersten beiden Nächte habe ich
woanders geschlafen ich hatte Angst weil
ich in dem Arbeitsvertrag den ich
unterschrieben hatte meine Adresse meine
Telefonnummer meine Passnummer und meine
Kontonummer angegeben hatte
sie sagten sie wüssten wo ich wohne dass
sie meine Telefonnummer und meine
IP-Adresse hätten und am nächsten Tag
schrieben sie mir das mein Leben von nun
an immer komplizierter werden würde wenn
ich meinen Auftrag nicht bis 17 Uhr
desselben Tages erfüllt hätte
mafias Hacker und digitale geldkuriere
ich habe viele Jahre im Verkauf
gearbeitet und letztes Jahr meinen Job
verloren
ich sah diese Anzeige für einen
Teilzeitjob es war angegeben dass ich
von zu Hause aus arbeiten kann
man brauchte einen Internetanschluss ein
Mobiltelefon und einen Computer
Internet die Bedingungen waren ungefähr
4 Stunden pro Tag für 2200 Euro
das ist nicht viel aber auch nicht zu
wenig
es hätte jedem passieren können aber es
passierte dieser Frau die wir zu Ihrer
Sicherheit Katja ronkin nennen werden
eine ehemalige verkaufsangestellte aus
der Gegend von Lugano auf der Suche nach
einem Job ihr Leidensweg begann im
September 2019 Euro
Anzeige auf der Plattform des SECO des
staatssekretariats für Wirtschaften
namens lovero Swiss
weil die regionalen Arbeitsämter jedem
Arbeitslosen Mitglied ein Passwort geben
mit dem sie die auf der Plattform
veröffentlichten Stellenangebote
überprüfen können ich nahm also an dass
es sich um ein ernsthaftes Angebot
handelte die Unternehmen die das Inserat
veröffentlichten waren real Villa und Co
mit Sitz in Paradiso und wir ist Tate
plus GmbH in lützlingen
also waren es zwei verschiedene Firmen
die beiden Unternehmen arbeiten zusammen
weil auf der Website einige Willen im
Tessin im sobra generie Soto chenri
angegeben waren
[Musik]
auf der Website wurde auch ein
Zertifikat der Eidgenossenschaft erwähnt
ein Qualitätszertifikat von Real Estate
Villa und Co wie Lenco es kam ihnen also
vertrauenswürdig vor mir
ja eine vertrauenswürdige Sache ich
spreche nicht sehr gut deutsch also habe
ich eine Online-Software benutzt um die
Anzeige zu übersetzen und die Aufgaben
erschien mir gut es ging um
Datenverarbeitung und
computerspeicherung
bevor sie die Bewerbung abschickte rief
Katja das Unternehmen an um weitere
Informationen zu erhalten
die Sprache mit einer Dame die sagte ihr
Name sein Milena Nida
Deutsch ich sprach Englisch sie sagte
ich müsste jeden Tag meine E-Mails
abrufen meine Aufgaben überprüfen und
sie im Laufe des Tages erledigen
Aufgaben wie Bearbeitung von Dokumenten
möglicherweise die Archivierung ich
hätte Zugang zu ihrer Plattform also
nahm mich an es sei eine Tessiner
Agentur die Ferienwohnungen vermietet
und verkauft
sich also und reichte alle geforderten
Unterlagen
einschließlich ihrer Kontonummer
nach ein paar Tagen erhielt sie zu ihrer
Überraschung eine positive Antwort und
der Vertrag wurde ihr per E-Mail in
deutscher Sprache zugesandt
wieso Keller miya compres und da meine
Deutschkenntnisse begrenzt waren
schickte ich den Vertrag an meine
Gewerkschaft um ihn überprüfen zu lassen
einen Moment und seufzte ich spreche
kein Deutsch ich kann Ihnen nicht helfen
also machte ich diese Copy Paste Übung
mit einer Online-Software und soweit ich
wusste sah er für mich in Ordnung aus
ich war glücklich denn immerhin hatte
ich schon einen Job gefunden zwar nur
ein Teilzeitjob aber immer noch besser
als nichts und ich hatte die Möglichkeit
eine andere Sprache zu üben und ein
anderes Gebiet auszuprobieren die
Immobilienbranche ich dachte ich würde
ein bisschen besser Deutsch lernen
man versucht die Zeit der
Arbeitslosigkeit so schnell wie möglich
zu beenden
auch weil wir verpflichtet sind
mindestens 12 Suchanfragen pro Monat zu
stellen und jede Art von Arbeit
unverzüglich
ich hatte also Angst dass ich wenn ich
die Stelle nicht annehme mit Strafen
überhäuft werde
hier wie Konfetti beim Karneval fallen
[Musik]
ein anderer Kanton ein anderer Stellen
Suchender der in die gleiche Falle
getappt ist
Nicoletti aus Freiburg hat jedoch einen
Vorteil er spricht gut deutsch und hat
im Personalwesen gearbeitet
ich wurde motiviert weil ich seit 2015
im Ruhestand war
und nachdem ich zwei oder drei Jahre
lang Spaß in der Gartenarbeit hatte
wollte ich mir eine Nebenbeschäftigung
in dieser Richtung suchen wo ich auch
unter Menschen bin ich war schon immer
gewohnt unter Leuten zu arbeiten auch
dank des Sports ich war lange Zeit
Fußballtrainer
Türkei und das hat mich veranlasst
wieder nach einer Beschäftigung zu
suchen
und wie wollten sie einen Job finden
ganz einfach ich habe meinen Lebenslauf
aktualisiert und bin dann ins Internet
gegangen ich erwähnte meine große
Berufserfahrung dass ich es gewohnt bin
unter Menschen zu sein und auch dass ich
es gewohnt bin Menschen zu führen ich
habe alle meine Unterlagen über meine
früheren Berufserfahrungen beigefügt und
natürlich auch erwähnt dass ich nicht
karriereorientiert bin ich bin ja fast
der Rentner war sich bewusst dass es ein
schwieriges Unterfangen werden würde und
stellte sich der Herausforderung auf
dieselbe Anzeige zu antworten die
bereits das Interesse von Katja ronkey
geweckt hatte
[Musik]
grundsätzlich war ich interessiert in
einem Job zwischen 30 und 50 Prozent
ich wollte keine festen Arbeitszeiten
mehr haben also habe ich diesen
Prozentsatz angegeben und dann ist mir
diese Anzeige aufgefallen
für 2200 Euro
ich dachte zwischen 30 und 50 % für 2200
€ sei ideal
ich habe mich beworben und sie haben
ziemlich schnell geantwortet und gesagt
jawohl so etwas wie mich suchen Sie
DJI
wissen Sie wenn man drei Jahre lang nach
einer Stelle sucht ist es überraschen
und wenngleich der erste oder zweite
schon sagt genauso etwas wie sie suchen
wir für mich war das eine freudige
Nachricht beigefügt war auch gleich der
Arbeitsvertrag dann habe ich gedacht
okay das ist wahnsinnig schnell aber die
kostet
in Anbetracht meiner Berufserfahrung
kamen mir dann aber doch Zweifel ich
sagte mir der bietet doch keiner 2200
Euro an ohne dich auch nur einmal
getroffen zu haben und meine Kompetenzen
zu können und auch aufgrund meiner
früheren Tätigkeit wo Geldwäsche bei
PostFinance ein großes Thema war kam mir
das in den Sinn
Nicoletti legte die Dinge auf Eis er
beschloss einige Nachforschungen über
real estate plus anzustellen und schrieb
eine weitere E-Mail an den
Personalleiter
ich habe dieser Frau Niederhaus
geschrieben und ihr einige sehr direkte
Fragen gestellt
wie kommt es dass Ihre Telefonnummer
nirgends zu finden ist ich habe
geschrieben was bedeuten die Punkte 4
und 4.3 im Vertrag die sich speziell auf
die Verpflichtungen bezogen und schrieb
sie bieten mir über 26.000 € pro Jahr
ohne mich kennenlernen zu wollen und ich
weiß seit ich bei PostFinance arbeite
wenn Verträge unterschrieben und dann
eingescannt werden dann ist das nicht
gültig
geworden
und wie man den Kirchenweg 39 findet
habe ich noch gefragt im Kirchenweg gab
es dort nur ein Haus das Architekt
[Musik]
was haben Sie zu diesem Zeitpunkt
gedacht ich hatte ein starkes Gefühl
dass da irgendetwas seltsam war und ich
dachte ich rufe besser diesen Herrn
Steiner an
mein kluger Schachzug denn Pascal
Steiner der Besitzer von Real Estate
plus hatte nicht nur keinen Job zu
vergeben sondern war selbst Opfer von
etwas geworden dass sich immer mehr als
mega betrug herausstellte für mich hat
die Geschichte so begonnen dass sich
seltsame Anrufe bekam
von Leuten die eine Stelle suchten
etwas schief laufen weil ich keine
Mitarbeiter suchte und auch sonst
niemand der in meiner Firma arbeitet
zuerst habe ich auch keinen Verdacht
geschöpft ich sagte den Leuten einfach
es handelt sich wahrscheinlich Irrtum
und sie sollen sich nicht mehr melden
erst später wurde ich auf die kriminelle
Absicht aufmerksam als ich von einem
Mann aus dem Kanton Freiburg kontaktiert
wurde der eine Stelle suchte
interessante dieser Mann schickte mir
auch die Unterlagen und den
Arbeitsvertrag in den der Firmenname
übernommen wurde
in den ersten zwei Wochen erhielt ich am
Tag vielleicht ein oder zwei Anrufe
später stellte ich fest dass diese
gefälschte Stellenanzeige auf viele
Plattformen aufgeschaltet wurde
und dann wurden aus ein oder zwei anruft
am Tag 10 bis 15
und wie viele Leute haben insgesamt
angerufen
ungefähr 70
gegen Unbekannt so fand der Architekt
heraus dass jemand angeblich Hacker eine
Webseite unter dem Namen seiner Firma
erstellt hatte
und er erstattete sofortanzeige die
meisten Anrufe kamen aus der Ostschweiz
gefolgt von Freiburg Bern Solothurn
Berner und natürlich aus dem Tessin das
Gespräch war immer das gleiche ich
musste aufpassen und freundlich sein
denn ich hätte die Beherrschung
verlieren können
ich musste arbeiten jedenfalls habe ich
immer versucht kurz zu erklären dass die
Anzeige gefälscht war
die meisten haben das sofort verstanden
sie fanden die Anzeige auch irgendwie
komisch
man verdient Geld indem man nichts tut
und man muss nichts können das war
irgendwie verdächtig
und die meisten sagten ja das ist mir
klar
es gibt Telefonate die mich besonders
berührt haben
ein Anruf kam von einem Mann der den
Vertrag schon unterschrieben hatte
er hatte den Betrügern seine Kontodaten
zur Verfügung gestellt und eine
Überweisung von 10.000 von Schweizer
Franken erhalten und dann wurde er
massiv bedroht damit er das Geld an eine
bestimmte Adresse schickt Post
ich gehe davon aus dass es natürlich um
Geldwäsche ging mir ist aufgefallen dass
viele der beteiligten Personen nicht
sehr gut deutsch oder eine andere
Landessprache beherrschen
und wahrscheinlich nicht einmal den
Vertrag gut lesen konnten oder
herausfanden dass der Text so viele
Rechtschreibfehler enthielt dass er
zumindest sehr verdächtig war
fotografieren
das ist Missbrauch denn die Menschen
handeln ja aus einer Schwäche heraus
wie ich heute gerade feststellen musste
sind die Anzeigen immer noch im Netz zu
finden
wir haben versucht diese Plattformen zu
stoppen aber es ist schwierig weil sie
meist im Ausland aktiv sind
es ist wie ein Katz und Mausspiel man
beantragt die Löschung auf einer
Plattform und sie wird auf einer anderen
wieder veröffentlicht und das ist ein
Problem wir sind praktisch machtlos
gegen diese missbräuchliche Verwendung
unseres Namens und solange das so
weitergeht können wir gar nichts mehr
machen
man fühlt sich wirklich missbraucht man
nimmt uns im Grunde eine solide Firma
mit all ihren Hintergründen
und man kann nichts dagegen machen
[Musik]
in der Zwischenzeit ist es uns gelungen
den Anwalt des Immobilienbüros in
Paradiso zu kontaktieren das anscheinend
eine Tochtergesellschaft von Pascal
Steiners Firma ist in Wirklichkeit
handelt es sich um zwei verschiedene
Unternehmen die Opfer desselben Betrugs
geworden sind und selbst im Fall des
Maklerbüros in Paradiso haben einige
Bewerber nicht nur angerufen um
Informationen zu erhalten sondern auch
direkt ihre unterschriebenen Verträge
geschickt
erste Vertrag am Anfang April 2019 der
zweite Vertrag wieder im April und der
dritte kam im Mai also beschlossen wir
etwas dagegen zu tun um die
Angelegenheit bei der Staatsanwaltschaft
anzuzeigen
lautizio die Anhörung der
Staatsanwaltschaft fand im Juli statt
haben sie sich gefragt warum gerade der
Name Iris Mandanten geklont wurde
natürlich haben wir uns gefragt warum
sie diese Firma gewählt haben aber wir
haben keine Antwort auf diese Frage
gefunden
ich vermute dass es unter anderem nach
Kriterien ausgewählt wurde die wir nicht
kennen
wir wissen nicht für welche Kriterien
sich die Verfasser diese Initiative
entschieden haben
vielleicht weil es nicht als Unternehmen
tätig war
ich weiß es nicht offen gesagt sollten
Sie diejenigen Fragen die diese
Entscheidung getroffen haben
was ist die Firma real estate Villa
Firma die nur eine Immobilie besitzt ihr
einziger Zweck ist es also diese
Immobilie zu verwalten und zu betreuen
wir wissen nicht nach welchen Kriterien
die Hacker die Unternehmen
identifizieren deren Namen sie stehlen
wollen aber anscheinend konzentrieren
Sie sich auf kleine Unternehmen die
keine Webseite haben und daher sehr
attraktiv für die Hacker sind die ein
Schaufenster brauchen auf dem sie ihre
Glaubwürdigkeit aufbauen können
wir haben beschlossen weiterzugehen und
nach der Anzeige zu suchen die Katja
ronkey und Nicoletti beantwortet haben
die Seite ist immer noch aktiv sie ist
grafisch identisch und sieht wie eine
perfekte Kopie der vorherigen Seite aus
zu diesem Zeitpunkt haben wir uns mit
einem falschen Namen beworben obwohl
sich zu unserer Überraschung der Name
des Unternehmens geändert hat jetzt
heißt es Alpha Swiss real estate mit
Sitz in Lugano
okay ich hatte in der Zwischenzeit
gehofft dass der erste Auftrag bald
kommt und dann kam er sehr früh am
Morgen
eine E-Mail in der Stadt du hast einen
Auftrag
in der Nacht schicken Sie eine Summe auf
mein Bankkonto auf dass sie mein Gehalt
zahlen sollten
wir haben
11.400 Schweizer Franken geschickt
holen Sie es sich in bar und rufen Sie
uns dann an
wenn möglich in 11.000 erscheinen und
zwei 200er scheinen
eine gelinde gesagt fragwürdige E-Mail
in der Katja ronkey konkrete Anweisungen
bekam sagen sie den Angestellten dass
sie Bargeld von Ihrem Girokonto abheben
wollen erwähnen sie nicht dass es für
das Geschäft die Arbeit oder eine
Immobilie ist sagen sie dass es sich um
eine private Transaktion für den
persönlichen Gebrauch handelt sie
könnten zum Beispiel sagen dass sie das
Geld für teure Medikamente brauchen
und was haben Sie gedacht
das ist merkwürdig war ich wollte es
herausfinden denn nach dem was ich in
dem vorangegangenen Telefonat
mitbekommen hatte hieß es das ist Leute
gebe die Ferienhäuser vermieten würden
ich habe also nicht verstanden warum sie
mir dieses Geld geschickt haben ich
wollte es abheben und rief dann an um
die Sache zu klären weil ich dachte ich
müsste eine Anzahlung für eine Wohnung
für jemanden leisten der in letzter
Minute anreisen würde
[Musik]
ich fragte wofür das Geld sei und sie
sagten ich würde innerhalb von zwei
Stunden eine E-Mail mit Anweisungen zum
weiteren Vorgehen erhalten
und dass ich das Geld bei mir behalten
sollte
haben sie sie irgendwie unter Druck
gesetzt
wenn ich meinen Auftrag innerhalb von 24
Stunden ausführen würde bekäme ich 90 €
extra und noch mehr Geld um die Kosten
zu decken
im Grunde wollten Sie dass dieses Geld
von Ihrem Konto verschwindet es sollte
sofort von meinem Konto abgehoben werden
ja
das einzige was wir haben um
herauszufinden wer hinter diesem
digitalen betrug steckt sind die
Adressen der Webseiten auf denen die
Stellenanzeigen veröffentlicht wurden
hinter jedem Domainnamen stehen
Kontoinhaber und Provider also die
Personen an die man sich wendet um
Eigentümer eines domaams zu werden wir
können diese Daten die öffentlich sind
einsehen und herausfinden woher die
Besitzer einer Website die wir besuchen
kommen
im Fall von release date plus wissen wir
dass sich die Seiten physisch auf einem
Computer befinden der auf einem Server
in den Niederlanden steht
gestern er wird von einem Unternehmen
betrieben dass diese Art von Service für
alle möglichen Webseiten anbietet
ist das normal
völlig normal ich kann Eigentümer einer
Website sein die sich in Luxemburg in
Frankreich oder in den Vereinigten
Staaten befindet so ist das im Internet
gibt es noch andere Informationen die
Sie gesehen haben coole diamo hier sehen
wir wo sie registriert wurde in diesem
Fall können wir an diesem dort ru sehen
dass sie bei einem russischen
Dienstleister registriert wurde achso
Russo an sich ist das nicht illegal aber
es gibt uns einen Hinweis auf die
Entscheidungen die die Leute getroffen
haben die die Website eröffnet haben es
gibt auch andere interessante Hinweise
die uns eine Vorstellung davon geben wer
hinter dieser Art von Geschäft stecken
könnte anstatt in einem einfachen Text
zu schreiben wurde eine grafische
Formulierung gewählt das ist ein in
diesem Bereich sehr verbreiteter Trick
um zu verhindern das Suchmaschinen wie
Google die Seite anzeigen wenn man nach
dem Unternehmen sucht
sehen das war die erste Firma inzwischen
sehen wir aber dass einen weiteren
Eintrag gibt der von einer Firma namens
Alpha Swiss real estate stammt
das erste Interessante an dieser zweiten
Domain ist dass Sie die exakte Kopie der
ersten ist das einzige was sich geändert
hat ist der grafische Streifen in dem
der Name der Firma steht die sie
imitieren auch hier der gleiche Trick
die Verwaltung des website-codes ist
identisch die verlinkten Dokumente sind
die gleichen
der einzige Unterschied besteht darin
dass sich der Server in der Republik
Moldau befindet
wie im vorherigen Fall haben wir die
gleiche Stelle bei der der Domain-Name
registriert wurde Russland
aber stecken wirklich dieselben Leute
hinter dieser Anzeige
das können wir nicht mit Sicherheit
sagen aber es ist ziemlich
wahrscheinlich ihre Arbeitsweise ist
dieselbe die Struktur der Website des
identisch einige Seiten richten sich
nicht an die Schweiz sondern zum
Beispiel am norwegische Kunden und sie
sind genau dieselben wenn Sie also
denselben Weg gehen sich auf dieselbe
Weise bewegen sind es wahrscheinlich
dieselben Leute ich gehe davon aus dass
es sich um das übliche Muster handelt
eine Bande von Betrügern die beschließt
einen Platz auf einem Server zu bekommen
um nicht blockiert zu werden nehmen Sie
mehrere auf verschiedenen Servern man
sollte nie alle Eier in einen Korb legen
auf diese Weise sind die anderen Server
die anderen Websites immer noch aktiv so
dass der Betrug an anderer Stelle
fortgesetzt werden kann wenn Sie zum
Beispiel wegen des Eingreifens der
Behörden geschlossen werden
ich denke es ist ganz logisch anzunehmen
dass derjenige der eine solche Aktivität
ins Leben gerufen hat eine Investition
tätigen wollte zwar eine illegale aber
dennoch eine Investition so dass die
Operation einen Ertrag abwerfen muss
unter einer bestimmten Größenordnung
macht eine solche Operation keinen Sinn
es handelt sich also sicherlich um 10
oder 100.000 von Schweizer Franken pro
Jahr
[Musik]
ein paar Tage sind seit unserer
Online-Bewerbung vergangen als wir eine
E-Mail erhalten der Absender ist ein
Züricher Unternehmen namens Smart
Support
das uns einen Job anbietet wir haben die
Adresse überprüft aber es gibt keine
Spur von einer solchen Firma diesmal
haben die Betrüger jedoch einen
deutlichen Qualitätssprung gemacht und
eine Homepage eingerichtet auf der sie
unter anderem die Namen ihrer
angeblichen Partnerfirmen angeben von
obs über Nestlé bis Migros
wenn sie mit einem Mitarbeiter der
Personalleitung sprechen möchten drücken
Sie die eins wenn Sie einen Verstoß
melden wollen
[Musik]
hallo willkommen bei one source ich bin
Vincenza wie kann ich Ihnen helfen ja
guten Morgen ist das Smartphone
nein sie haben die falsche Nummer das
ist die Firma SD nur der
aber diese Nummer ist die Nummer der
Firma Smart supporte in Zürich
nein vielleicht haben sie sie geändert
das ist unsere Nummer wirklich wir sind
nicht diese Firma wir sind SDO der sie
sind SDO der
[Musik]
es war bereits Dezember als wir aus Den
Haag die Nachricht von einer großen
Polizeirazzia erhielten die von Europol
durchgeführt wurde der Name der
Operation Emma five European Action
ergänzt money News und wieso liestaloni
digital
zu waschen nicht weniger als 31 Nationen
waren an der Razzia beteiligt
während der fünften europäischen
geldschmuggelaktion haben wir mehr als
3.800 geldschmuckler identifiziert über
650 Banken haben mit uns
zusammengearbeitet und ich denke das
zeigt dass wir mit der richtigen
Zusammenarbeit sehr erfolgreich sein
können
mit Emma 5 ist es uns gelungen auf der
Grundlage der von uns ermittelten
Transaktionen rund 13 Millionen Euro zu
blockieren die nicht in die Hände von
Kriminellen gelangt sind
ziemlich schwierig es gibt viele
Herausforderungen die wir als
Ermittlungsbehörden bewältigen müssen
wir haben auch große Schwierigkeiten die
Rechtssysteme der beteiligten Länder
aufeinander abzustimmen
in der Tat haben wir große Probleme im
rechtlichen Bereich wenn wir Rechtshilfe
ersuchen benötigen kann das sehr lange
dauern und die Rechtsgrundlagen sind
nicht immer klar wenn wir in
verschiedenen Ländern arbeiten
und natürlich ist es zum Beispiel bei
der Cyberkriminalität sehr selten dass
ein Verbrechen nur in der Schweiz
stattfindet und dass sich das Opfer der
Kriminelle und die Infrastruktur in
einem Land befinden sie sind in der
Regel über verschiedene Länder verstreut
und werden von den Kriminellen oft so
ausgewählt dass sie in bestimmten
Ländern stattfinden in denen die
rechtliche Zusammenarbeit vielleicht
nicht so gut funktioniert wie in anderen
Ländern
und nicht nur das im Internet machen
Hacker Geschäfte mit dem organisierten
Verbrechen
und es ist letzteres das den Hackern die
digitalen Geld Kuriere liefert um Geld
zu waschen das von den Banken
ahnungsloser Bürger gestohlen wurde
wenn ich zum Beispiel als
cyberkrimineller oder Hacker eine
Verschlüsselungssoftware entwickelt habe
und einen Angriff gestartet habe und die
Zahlungen kommen rein und ich will das
Geld waschen
die Kuriere sind eine große Gruppe die
über verschiedene Länder verteilt sind
und sie erbringen die Dienstleistung die
das organisierte Verbrechen mir anbietet
das bedeutet dass ich mich als Hacker an
die mafias wenden kann die diese
gelddesel als reguläre Dienstleistung
anbieten
und wer sind diese geldsel das sind im
Regelfall Personen die auf einen
scheinbar legales Angebot reagiert haben
zum Beispiel einen Jobangebote in dem
behauptet wird sie könnten von zu Hause
aus arbeiten einen bestimmten Geldbetrag
verdienen und müssten lediglich ihr
Konto für einige Transaktionen zur
Verfügung stellen
auf Ihr Konto erhalten Sie dann einen
Betrag den Sie weiterleiten müssen und
von dem sie wahrscheinlich einen kleinen
Teil behalten können
an der europolacia waren auch vier
Kantone beteiligt Zürich Basel Bad und
Aargau
auf den Konten der Schweizer
drogenkoriere wurden mehr als 7
Millionen Euro gesperrt
175 geld-esel wurden identifiziert und
Opfer deren Bankkonten geknackt worden
und schließlich wurden 45 Ermittlungen
von den vier kantonalen
Staatsanwaltschaften eingeleitet aber
die Teilnahme an der Operation war
freiwillig und das Tessin hat sich
geweigert sich anzuschließen
so dass der Fall Katja ronkey noch offen
ist und wir wollen mehr herausfinden was
haben sie mit dem Geld gemacht haben sie
es abgehoben und hierher gebracht
ja ich habe es mit nach Hause genommen
zuerst dachte ich es sei schmutziges
Geld der Erlös aus dem Verkauf der nicht
in den Kreislauf gebracht werden konnte
[Musik]
denn selbst wenn nur zehn von uns auf
diese Anzeige antworten würden pro
Person 11.000 Franken jede Woche
dann würden sie schnell 10 Millionen in
bar machen oder
und woher kam das Geld auf ihrem Konto
das war nur eine Reihe von Zahlen und
der Name
dieser ubs-kunde war also das
vorgelagerte Opfer dieses Betrugs von
seinem Konto hatten die Hacker die
11.400 Franken gestohlen die auf das
Konto von Katja ronkey umgeleitet wurden
im Moment sind einige der häufigsten
Methoden um Geld von einem Girokonto zu
stehlen diese man kann zum Beispiel den
Computer infizieren der für das
Homebanking verwendet wird so dass der
Benutzer sein Homebanking aufruft einen
normalen Vorgang durchführt und nicht
weiß dass er über seine eigene Webcam
die in den Bildschirm vieler Laptops
eingebaut ist beobachtet wird
natürlich
der Betrüger wartet darauf dass der
Benutzer geht aber nimmt die Kontrolle
über Maus und Tastatur und für deine
weitere Transaktion durch 13 Jahren das
ist eine ausgefallene Technik aber es
gibt auch andere die hauptsächlich auf
Psychologie beruhen sie erhalten zum
Beispiel eine Mitteilung in Papierform
in der heiß ist es gibt ein Problem mit
Ihrem Konto wir haben es zu Ihrer
Sicherheit gesperrt der Briefkopf sieht
authentisch aus bitte rufen Sie diese
Nummer an der Kundenservice ist für sie
da Probleme
maximale queston numero das Opfer ruft
die Nummer an die zwar einem Betrüger
gehört aber offenbar eine
kundenbetreuungsnummer ist
die assistenza der Betrüger geht ran und
gibt sich als Bankangestellter aus keine
Sorge wir werden Ihnen helfen das ist
also Ihre Kontonummer und das ist ihre
PIN richtig normalerweise sagt das Opfer
am anderen Ende nein das ist es nicht
das ist meine PIN
und Betrüger
wir wissen nicht ob dies in unserem Fall
passiert ist wir konnten aber das Opfer
des Betrugs ausfindig machen einen
Herren aus Zürich er bestätigte zwar den
Sachverhalt wollte uns aber kein
Interview geben ebenso wenig wie die UBS
die Bank bei der sich der Notgroschen in
Luft aufgelöst hatte wir mussten der
einzigen wirklichen Spur in der Hand
unseres Zeugen folgen
wo sollte das Geld denn hin das Geld war
für einen Herrn oleg-
und Sie wissen nicht ob er existiert
nein ich wollte nicht einmal nachschauen
weil ich so viel Angst hatte dass sie
auch meinen Datenverkehr überprüfen
würden nachdem sie mir gesagt hatten
dass sie meine IP-Adresse haben
natürlich
[Musik]
etwa 97 98 gab es einen Boom einen
richtigen Goldrausch für russische
Hacker
als sie merken dass sie mit Hecking eine
Menge Geld verdienen konnten
[Musik]
Daniel Turowski investigativer
Journalist ist ein Star auf seinem
Gebiet Seite einen wichtigen Aufsatz
über russische Hacker und ihre
Zusammenarbeit mit dem Kreml
veröffentlicht hatte war er ins Visier
seiner Gegner geraten so sehr dass wir
nicht einmal seinen Computerbildschirm
Filmen durften weil es zu riskant war
die zweite Generation der Hacker geht
auf die frühen 2000er Jahre zurück
das waren Leute die mit diesem System
bereits reich geworden waren
sie begannen sich in Gruppen zusammen zu
schließen die Waren in einer Weise
organisiert die eine italienische
mafiabanten erinnert
zu dieser Zeit genossen die Hacker eine
große Freiheit als in Russland keine
speziellen Gesetze zur Unterdrückung
dieser Art von Aktivitäten gab
so dass sie nicht strafrechtlich
verfolgt werden konnten
erinnern sich an diese Zeit als das
goldene Zeitalter
[Musik]
aber die wirkliche Revolution war 2012
als die ersten cyberkriegsangriffe unter
dem Kommando der russischen Behörden
gestartet worden
sie begannen junge und talentierte
Universitätsstudenten zur rekrutieren um
sich mit einigen Bereichen der
cybersicherheit zu beschäftigen
zur gleichen Zeit begannen die ersten
Experimente mit seiner Angriffen
diese hacker sind viele einige hundert
und sie sind gezwungen für die
Spezialeinheiten zu arbeiten wenn sie
nicht ins Gefängnis wollen
normalerweise werden die Hacker
gezwungen sich zu entscheiden da sie
erwischt werden wenn Sie große Angriffe
auf russische Banken oder russische
Kunden verüben
danach werden sie in den meisten Fällen
zu einer Befragung vorgeladen zum
Beispiel von den Geheimdiensten der
Russischen Föderation oder in anderen
Ministerien wo sie die Wahl haben
entweder im Gefängnis zu landen oder mit
dieser Institution zu kooperieren
in der Regel entscheiden sich fast alle
für eine Zusammenarbeit und führen
verschiedene Aufträge aus
es kommt aber auch vor dass einige von
ihnen gegen Bezahlung bei größeren
Angriffen auf einen anderen Staat
angeheuert werden manchmal sind diese
Angriffe das Werk illegaler Hacker
wenn ich das richtig verstehe bedeutet
das dass die Geheimdienste diese Hacker
für ihre eigenen Zwecke einsetzen sie
aber in die Konten anderer Länder
eindringen lassen malila Rico und Tina
ja genau unter den Hackern die für die
Spezialeinheiten Arbeiten gibt es auch
solche die die Sicherheitssysteme der
Banken aus Profit Gründen aushebeln
[Musik]
das Cyberkriminalität von den Behörden
geduldet zu werden scheint ist
cybersicherheit heute ein
Milliardengeschäft und in Russland der
unbestrittenen Heimat der Hacker sind
einige internationale Giganten aus dem
Boden geschossen die Sicherheitsgeräte
für Unternehmen und Privatpersonen
anbieten die ib-
[Musik]
entwickeln deine Vielzahl von Werkzeugen
um Cyberangriffe durchzuführen um
Informationen zu stehen private
Informationen wie Bankkonten
Kreditkarten und so weiter
in unserer Agentur haben wir
festgestellt dass diese Cyberkriminellen
ihre Werkzeuge zunächst in Russland und
anderen östlichen Ländern testen
nachdem sie zwei Jahre lang Angriffe in
Russland durchgeführt haben ziehen sie
in europäische Länder oder asiatische
Region
es liegt also an Einzelpersonen und
insbesondere an den Banken ihre eigenen
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen ständig zu
aktualisieren um cyberlex zu vermeiden
[Musik]
heutzutage geben Banken und Unternehmen
viel Geld aus um ihre Systeme zu
schützen
deswegen ist es im Moment nicht einfach
Menschen mit bestimmter Malware
anzugreifen
Systeme zur Verhaltensanalyse um ihre
betrugsbekämpfungssysteme zu verbessern
sie können erkennen ob sich jemand in
ein Konto eingeloggt und versucht hat
Geld zu überweisen
die Banken sind in der Lage diese Art
von ungewöhnlichen Verhalten zu erkennen
und die Überweisung von Geld zu
verhindern
meine Transfers aber wie finden Sie
heraus ob es der Kontoinhaber ist der
eine Transaktion durchführt oder ein
Krimineller
also normalerweise bieten wir diese
Dienste an die man sicheres Banking und
sicheres Portal nennt
diese Systeme sammeln Informationen über
das Benutzerverhalten und wenn sich
jemand anderes bei einem Bankkonto
anmeldet vergleichen wir das Verhalten
dieser speziellen Episode mit allen
früheren Verhaltensweisen des echten
Kunden
und wenn wir etwas feststellen dass
anders ist geben wir die Informationen
an die Bank weiter Information
verwenden
Sie mit Verhalten
zum Beispiel ihre Tippgeschwindigkeit
oder wie Sie den Cursor bewegen
zum Beispiel Informationen über die
IP-Adresse die sie für den
Internetzugang verwenden all diese
Informationen werden von unseren
Systemen gesammelt und analysiert können
Schweizer Bankkonten generell als sicher
angesehen werden
im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern glaube
ich dass die Schweizer Banken sicher
sind
aber in diesem Jahr haben wir Verstöße
bei über 10.000 Konten und Kreditkarten
festgestellt die Schweizer Banken
gehören
[Musik]
herausgefunden
mindestens 10.000 Schweizer Bankkunden
sind in diesem Jahr betrogen worden
diese Tatsache ist besorgniserregend da
es sich dabei um die Verletzten konnten
handelt die von einer einzigen
cybersicherheitsagentur entdeckt wurden
wer weiß vielleicht war auch der
Betrogene obs-
eine Frage die wir auch den russischen
Behörden gestellt haben doch wir
erhielten nie eine Antwort fest steht
dieses Geld sollte genau hier in Moskau
Ankommen in der wavilova-allee 3 wo wir
ein Haus zu finden glaubten ist in
Wirklichkeit ein riesiges
Einkaufszentrum
und wenn der Umschlag hier ankam wer
sollte ihn dann abholen ist wirklich der
Empfänger des Geldes oder ist es nur ein
Name
ja guten Morgen Ich muss wissen wie ich
einen Briefkasten mit dieser Adresse
mieten kann kann ich mit ihnen darüber
sprechen mir wurde gesagt dass sie mir
die Informationen geben können ich bin
ein Unternehmer ich habe ausländische
Kollegen und wir brauchen einen
Briefkasten man sagte mir ich solle zu
ihrem Einkaufszentrum kommen
was genau man sie
ein Briefkasten für die Korrespondenz da
wir kein Büro haben aber eine offizielle
Postanschrift für unsere Adresse für
unsere Korrespondenz benötigen
sind sie hier Pächter
nein wir brauchen nur einen Briefkasten
sie müssen einen Mietvertrag haben um
unsere Adresse zu bekommen sonst wird
ihm niemand einen Briefkasten geben
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht
versuchen Sie die Geschäftsleitung zu
fragen
hallo hallo entschuldigen Sie ich suche
Olek juraf einen Mieter können Sie uns
etwas sagen sie sind der Typ der vorhin
angerufen hat glaube ich ich habe ihnen
schon gesagt dass gibt es eine Liste von
Mietern die ich mir ansehen könnte
selbst wenn wir eine solche Liste hätten
[Musik]
wie auch immer es gibt hier niemanden
mit diesem Namen
gibt es diesen Mitarbeiter wirklich
nicht hier nein den gibt es nicht
in unserer Verwaltung gibt es niemanden
mit diesem Namen
ich musste also das Geld nehmen und es
nach Moskau schicken
ich fand die Sache natürlich sehr
seltsam um es mal so zu sagen
also habe ich versucht es hinauszuzögern
und herauszufinden was ich tun sollte
also schrieb ich E-Mails und fragte
welche Art von Umschlag ich verwenden
sollte einen C4 oder einen C5 welche
Farbe
eigentlich habe ich das Geld sofort an
den Absender zurückgeschickt ich sagte
dass das Geld nicht mir gehöre und sie
ist zurückschicken müssten ich musste
warten bis die Bank wieder öffnete zwei
Stunden später
sie leben alleine fühlen sie sich sicher
am Anfang nicht ich habe sogar einige
Freunde um Hilfe gebeten ich habe meine
Freunde gefragt
in den ersten beiden Nächten habe ich
woanders geschlafen ich fühlte mich
nicht in der Lage dazu
ich bekam einige bizarre SMS und am
nächsten Morgen schrieben Sie mir eine
E-Mail in der sie sagten sie hätten
einen Vertrag unterschrieben
meine Aufgaben sein klar und es gäbe
nichts illegales und sie hätten ihre
Anwälte und mein Leben würde von nun an
immer komplizierter werden
aber am Tag davor bekam ich Angst also
versuchte ich die Kantonspolizei zu
kontaktieren und erstattete Anzeige
[Musik]